[Music]
who's already seen this mike tyson video
i saw a little bit of it this morning i
saw it this morning right when i woke up
it was so good i just saw him chatting
[ __ ] with the guy but then
afterwards i saw their reaction and that
was it that was the only thing i saw you
have no i've never seen this all right
we're gonna we're gonna get an authentic
reaction then from christian because he
hasn't seen this yet but this just
happened
[Music]
is that business class it looks pretty
nice yeah it's like business or first is
it delta or united jet blue jet blue
business class
video talking [ __ ] derek lewis he posted
that's where i saw it yeah and it's the
whole video that they got from the
beginning all the way to oh it's the
whole uncut thing all the way not uncut
there's clips but it's like all the
clips then him getting hit and then him
afterwards the lead up to it it was him
like meeting him too right so was
someone like oh cause it's his friend it
was it was his friend recording yeah
yeah let's do that clip because yeah
that one's pretty funny hey you ain't
got eye blocker
i need to get a hat blocker too i could
try to find something to send you
oh here we go
mike tyson's by language is like get me
the [ __ ] is this bro you could tell
because you're not even turned around
once
mike types are trying to give us some
shirts
man he's killing his trip right
tyson looking out man and you can tell
this guy's blitz bro i never gave you
his money
what did he say he said that he hasn't
you just want this guy punched so bad uh
he's just so annoying looking yeah yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
so i read the summary he went up
and
you know mike tyson was being cool
took pictures with them it was fine and
his food just kept talking and mike was
like hey man chill and then he kept
talking and talking and apparently he
was drunk
and then so you know those obnoxious
drunk [ __ ] right they just
don't know when to stop some people i
just smell alcohol in their breath and i
want to [ __ ] poke their eyes out yeah
they're not even doing anything wrong
they're just having a good time they're
just and i could smell [ __ ] beer and
i want to kill them in my tyson
in my tyson's defense too he didn't sock
him once
he just shook at the floor he's just
shaking him maybe it just looked like
you know like just slapping like he was
just like trying to get him to calm down
he wasn't hitting him like that no when
i was reading the article like a lot of
people were blowing it out of proportion
like oh he sucked him up i'm like dude
we've seen him fight yeah like he did
not fight he did not punch him one time
like he was not like a shoulder rotated
like wow you know it kind of looked like
he was like hitting his arm yeah just
look like stop [ __ ] i [ __ ] told
you
he was spanking him why did he have all
those little marks too because he's a
[ __ ] that guy's a [ __ ] yeah when you
get slapped in his arm it travels
he was getting shook he started bleeding
and my tyson's slap is probably very
that's his weakness don't shake me i'll
bleed
mike tyson's so strong he cut him up
shaking him shakes the blood out of your
pores when i was reading the comments of
like people when they're when this was
being posted they're like why doesn't he
fly private dude [ __ ] why dude i've seen
a lot of celebrities like flying
commercial all the time dude it's like
so expensive to fly private too you know
i mean like all the time but it's also
like i think people are just
assuming everything where like sometimes
people need a emergency flight yeah or
when you fly private maybe there's only
two takeoffs during that you need to go
now yeah
even if you fly private do you have your
own pilot do you have your own plane do
you have like all those things take into
consideration like sometimes they're
just not available yeah charter flights
yeah i like how the commenter is making
it mike tyson's fault
if he would have flown private this
would never have happened
the people that came into defense
they're like why can't people just leave
him alone exactly
why can't he just fly like why can't he
save his money and just fly commercial
and then the eco-friendly argument comes
and they're like well maybe he doesn't
want to spend all his money and [ __ ]
hurt the environment flying private all
the time there it is there's down equal
point to this yeah yeah also knowing
that
also knowing that mike tyson that we all
know now
that was probably sad as [ __ ] after this
like i think mike tyson he's been trying
to like throw away his old image right
it's all about loving [ __ ] love
everybody
i told him to behave
and he's gone a long time yeah it took
him a long time to get that [ __ ]
inner warrior out and then now [ __ ]
this guy brought it out of him he's
about [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] i feel
like really sorry for what he did i'm
surprised he doesn't travel with
entourage or anybody else so they could
beat his ass yeah exactly but then maybe
because it's mike tyson he doesn't need
it in that video was his buddy holding
him back was that it was
oh yeah the guy sitting next to mike was
like trying to well that's that's what a
lot of people are saying is like that's
the point of security is not it's not
like even though mike's a warrior it's
like your security's supposed to be the
one to take the [ __ ] for you yeah yeah
yeah like they're the ones that are
supposed to like kind of if shit's going
to go down if i was mike tyson's homie i
would never hold him back i can't wait
let me see left hook my toes
left hook this one's been talking [ __ ]
about you left hook
[Laughter]
see 36 c they need to get sucked slip
under
people will be tested did you he just
had that other thing too where the guy
at that comedy show comedy show yeah
yeah and he and he didn't do he was like
super cool about that everybody's
testing imagine the guy that pulled out
a gun acted way better than this [ __ ]
guy
all the rankings and like this guy sucks
whoever sat behind him and it's it's
everything you shouldn't do when you see
a famous person but just like
he just looks annoying that guy like his
face well isn't there a mike tyson quote
that people were saying like they're all
citing this quote where he said like
nowadays people are getting used to
talking [ __ ] and not getting punched in
the face yeah yeah
he looks so sad afterwards here yeah he
looks like ridiculous that kid reminds
me reminds me of like every single
person i knew growing up that was the
type that was like the way you wanna
fight away whatever he's like all up in
your face and then when they get punched
like oh my god what are you doing he's
gonna call the cops he's like that yeah
immediately all we're trying to do is
ask for an autograph it's like i'm gonna
shut the [ __ ] up dude that's that's the
dumbest thing too that's the dumbest
thing too is that commentary here i
don't know what happened yeah she's like
no you do know what happened i sucked
the [ __ ] up that's why they should just
round up him and his friends and just
everybody on the plane [ __ ] him up
because obviously their parents didn't
do it they do they say it on the
intercom all right guys we're going to
punch these uh
on your way out everybody just give them
a good old and the [ __ ] because the
other homie didn't keep him in check
yeah yeah the other homemade yo he's
mike tyson chilled out you know and why
were they sitting next to each other
yeah what's up with that i think both of
those again yeah i wonder if he like
moved his seat on purpose and sat behind
tyson just to [ __ ] with him oh i hate
that these types of people can afford
first class he probably got bumped up
dude that [ __ ] makes me feel silly i
mean he already has like a kind of a
privileged person have you guys ever
like been in a plane with drunk people
though
yeah yeah it sucks so annoying this was
mid-flight too right no it was before it
even took off right oh i thought it was
like in the air he came on drunk yeah
after he socked him mike left the plane
oh okay
and then and then when the plane flew
and landed at the destination then
the dude went to the cops like at that
location what a [ __ ] would it destroy
business if they banned alcohol
from planes and like
bars
well do they charge for alcohol i think
it's free right would it destroy the
business of flights because do people
like i'm only flying
probably some people get like anxious
and [ __ ] because i heard that the the
like most people just drink to chill out
like on planes or not just to relax
on jetblue i have a mosaic which is like
when you fly enough you get like the
reward tears mosaics like the highest
one mosaic you get free alcohol wow i
just get hammered and pass out though
see that's nice you're not belligerent
no yeah i passed out i wake up pass out
my journal business yeah yeah that's the
way to do it hung over i'm like why did
i do that do it every time
you're the passed out guy where your
friend's like yo you were sitting next
to mike tyson you're like oh me you're
sleeping on a shoulder
[Laughter]
you never had a situation where like
some like a fan was bugging the [ __ ] out
of you and
oh man just the other [ __ ] month i
wanted to [ __ ] pop that dumb [ __ ] in
the face i just try to get him to talk
about it and he looked over here too and
he knew that joe was gonna respond
i was trying to direct the energy that
guy sucked though dude what happened
that guy sucked he was socially ill is
what i would he was socially ill i like
that nah he came up to me socially ill
and then he would just like hey remember
me and i'm like oh my god
dude remember me is the best way to go
up to a famous person and i'm like why
would i remember me for me
hey dude yeah and then he's like and
then yeah what did you say you were like
what did you do
i was like what did you do how would i
remember you
no at first it was kind of cool it was
normal it was like hey joe you know and
i'm like hey what landmark
yeah what impression did you make on me
and then i was like i was like hey
what's up it was cool and then he just
stood there and he was like staring at
me oh and i'm like remember me and i'm
like
i'm like from where he goes no remember
i was there in that truck and i'm like
what you don't remember and i'm like did
you do something remarkable
did you do something like what did you
do remember me i was i waved at you from
the truck and i'm like when what a
letdown how do i remember you i was in
the truck
i waved at you you're not gonna give me
a color you're not gonna give me
anything else i waved at you
in the truck i was in the truck so i was
like did we do something eventful
together like did we share a memory
like did you know was there a moment
between us that
i wouldn't remember did we invest in a
business together like what the [ __ ] you
know like speak [ __ ] you know
and i was like at first it wasn't that
that weird was just like oh that was it
he escalated right it [ __ ] escalated
right and he came up and he goes hey do
you know this person he drove the truck
they're like which who you talking about
and i was like who which guy are you
talking about you know he rolled up the
window
and he he mentioned a name and i'm like
who the [ __ ] is this that name sounds
familiar
and then the thing is this guy would
just ask a question without
like deliberating anything about it you
just ask a question
do you remember this name
this person's name you know
what about them like guess who the
[ __ ] exactly
where did you go
are you familiar with crayola yeah
you're like what the [ __ ] about crayola
what about it though like he's like you
don't remember you don't remember me
crayola big fan were you trapped like
were you out of like i don't know you're
at a restaurant
joe's in a corner literally like do you
remember me
that guy did really get close but then
he kept wanting to shake your hand
he called my friend and then he put me
on facetime and i'm like okay
so i talked to him and i'm like okay
he's i guess he's a mutual friend so so
like i guess uh this is okay because
when you know someone that knows someone
it's like all right whatever he's not
that
weird so we're eating and at the end
right he walks up and he goes joe can i
tell you something and i'm like nah you
said enough nah i don't want to talk to
you i said you can't tell me he goes
please i need to tell you something and
i'm like
nah dude you can't he goes please and
i'm like all right what he goes did you
know jesus christ died for our sins and
i'm like shut the [ __ ] up and i pushed
him and i walked away he really said
that to you oh my god did you see me
that i pushed him well because when he
came this guy
i remember he came up to you
a second time and i never seen joe look
annoyed like ever this dude
joe's face i was like oh joe might have
sucked this dude i'ma leave i felt
uncomfortable because this guy was
making me feel uncomfortable so we all
left and i didn't know the rest of it
damn i didn't know he wanted you to go
to his church
did you know jesus christ died for our
sins and he did this and he resurrected
and i was just like shut the [ __ ] up and
i pushed him off
[ __ ]
and i walked away and it's like yeah bro
everybody knows that
everybody knows jesus christ died for
our sins okay
what did he think what's gonna happen
was at that moment i was gonna be like
wow damn he died that's crazy like you
know what i do remember you
screaming this dude in the middle of the
[ __ ] restaurant i was like he was
screaming this trying to preach
everybody was uncomfortable yeah his
friends from the table were just looking
at the table like i'm so sorry and i
called my friend i was like hey you know
you better talk to your friend because
if i didn't know him and it wasn't like
a mutual situation i swear to god i
would have dragged him outside and
[ __ ] kicked his ass
only because it would have made me feel
good like it was one of those situations
where you just gotta slap a dude and i
was like man i don't know like your
relation to him if you guys are good
friends but i'm like you gotta talk to
him and he goes oh i'm sorry he's my
friend's crazy and i'm like what do you
mean he goes yeah he's just [ __ ]
weird like that he didn't warn you on
facetime he didn't tell me yeah he
didn't go
he did look a little like bewildered
he looked like caught off surprise
though he was like like
hey what's up joe
like why the [ __ ] is this guy facetiming
me so that i can talk to joe and kind of
vouch for him like this is weird i don't
even want to be on facetime right now it
was a good time
and i'm glad you accepted jesus christ
through the lord yeah
for the third time
he's like so the next day i went to his
church i remembered him
[ __ ] everybody
you beat everybody up in the church
[Music]
my